welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the spider-man no way home
trailer was filled with multiversal
intrigue multi-generational fan service
and
god damn it what's that doing in there i
was perfectly happy to look past this
and move on with my theory whips with
within but most of us are pretty weirded
out by doctor strange in this trailer
why does he so quickly agree to help
peter with a spell that threatens the
fabric of reality and then admonish the
kid when it falls apart from the
slightest interference based on a number
of clues and this film's obvious comic
inspiration many of you are fairly
asking could doctor strange be under the
influence of or himself be an illusion
cast by lift in the sensors here
marvel's devil mephisto
it is the number one question i keep
getting and as your subservient nerd
theorist
explainer i am going to answer this to
the best of my ability even if it kills
me and damns my soul but before you
comment that this is the one division
mephisto train all over again like i
could catch you before you wrote that i
know 90 of you just kneed your comment
directly on the thumbnail without
watching the video seriously why why are
you the way that you are while i am
personally bound to mephisto in all
corners of my life due to a blood curse
i don't want to get into it i am also
perfectly capable of recognizing that
mephisto does not belong in every marvel
title even when loki's first episode
included a freaking devil sighting i
shot it down and stuck to my theory guns
that it was kang all along thank you god
i get to keep my job and jonathan magers
has never looked sexier my support of
mephisto and wandavision came mostly
from that series strong parallels to the
west coast avenger comics involving
agatha harkness memory wiping and
wanda's children that revealed mobisto
pulling the strings now yes some fans
got carried away pointing at everything
as hashtag mephisto confirmed but at the
end of the day i don't think it was that
crazy to look for the devil in the
details in a show about witchcraft but
now going into spider-man no way home i
did not expect mephisto to be involved
in this at all because this movie is
packed enough with multiversal magic
peter angst and endless cameos to have
time for faustian bargains but then this
damn trailer drags me back into the hell
mouth because peter responds to mysterio
and j jonah jameson exposing his
identity and ruining his life by asking
doctor strange to rewind everyone's
memories but then gets second thoughts
when it comes to his girlfriend his best
friend and his aunt can't some people
still know that's not how the spell
works so mj's gonna forget about
everything stop tampering with the spell
ned he's my best friend oh my aunt may
should really stop talking
what just happened this sticks pretty
close to the plot of one more day which
begins with peter parker asking dr
strange for help to save a dying aunt
may and then turns to someone later
revealed to be mephisto in disguise and
peter makes a deal with the devil to
warp reality so that peter's spider-man
identity is secret once more but with
major consequences to his girlfriend and
his best friend so to think mephisto
could be involved in this movie it's not
that far out of left field but perhaps
the biggest wtf moment from the trailer
was the fact that doctor strange accepts
peter's request with no hesitation just
a lie to wong and a wink this isn't the
doctor strange that we know who when
approached for help by thor and tony
stark toyed with them and helped with
only the slightest assists that in some
cases involved manipulating them into
killing themselves also weird strange
here where's the eye of agamotto despite
that being destroyed by thanos and
infinity war and strange having no need
for it since the time stone was atomized
now peter might not know the necklace
was destroyed because during that wizard
duel between strange and thanos peter
was busy saving the guardians from
floating away some are also pointing to
strange's hair because yeah in past mcu
films he tends to always have a somewhat
messy curl dropping over his forehead
but here it seems mostly neat also he
feels weird being called steven and his
sanctum is mysteriously frozen over like
the ninth circle of hell yet he can cast
a blazing fire with a snap of his
fingers also his mug bears disgusting
profanity okay yes i am reaching with
some of these really it's strange's
attitude toward peter antagonizing him
for expressing typical teenage doubt for
a spell strange should have known better
than to expose peter to the problem is
you trying to live two different lives
no it's not the problem is you steven
strange breaking wizard code to win over
a dopey nerd and footage shows strange
combating peter in a wizard duel on a
speeding train and knocking his astral
projection out of his body an attempt to
snatch back this mysterious cube which i
had proposed could be a pocket prison to
contain extra dimensional entities which
peter himself gets trapped in but thanks
to hellofresh for sponsoring this video
get mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
fresh pre-measured ingredients delivered
right to your door with hellofresh
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable i like cooking but i don't
have a ton of extra time to plan or prep
and i love how hellofresh helps you save
time and stress you can get some tasty
home-cooked food on the table in just 20
minutes with their quick and easy
options hellofresh offers so many
recipes to choose from each week to help
you break out of that frozen pizza mac
and cheese death spiral it's flexible to
fit your lifestyle easily change your
delivery days or food preferences and
skip a week whenever you need and it's a
nice little nod to our friend the planet
the packaging hellofresh uses to ship
your food is almost entirely made from
recyclable or recycled content it's
always a thrill to unbox a hello fresh
delivery and to have all your
ingredients sorted into these little
bags just oddly satisfying and then last
night i made one of those three the
firecracker meatballs let's do this i
felt like a pro okay so i'm supposed to
have fluffed the rice i might have
cooked it too long but i i uh
compensated later and looks kind of
fluffy i think i did it
oh shoot i'm supposed to be getting
stuff out of the oven
some green beans and some
uh meatballs oil cracker meatballs
actually turned out pretty good it
smells good their meals are really
delicious with more five-star rated
recipes than any other meal kit service
bon appetit so go to hellofresh.com and
use the code
rockstars14 to get 14 free meals plus
free shipping that's code rockstars 14
at hellofresh.com to get 14 free meals
plus free shipping trailer ends with
strange warning in a dark tone be
careful what you wish for parker which
again contextualizes all of this as a
wish fulfillment plot gone awry much
like one more day which again was a
mephisto operation now i think it is
reasonable for fans to suspect some
deception here and not just because of
that devil in disguise poster i mean
have you been to any protest people
putting devil horns on everybody but
really because all of these mcu
spider-man movies have been about to
some extent deception tony stark fooled
peter by making him think he was in that
iron man suit just to reveal it was
empty and remote piloted and then later
double fakes him by actually showing up
in it peter is totally caught off guard
when his homecoming dates dad is the
criminal he had been chasing leading to
the two of them trying to out deceive
each other and then at the end of the
movie tony again deceives peter by
making him think there was no press
conference when on the other side of
that door there totally was and then far
from home is of course an even bigger
deception game on peter parker with
mysterio gaslighting him again and again
even stalking him since the beginning of
that movie and even peter's allies were
actually shape-shifting aliens in
disguise see folks we have been primed
to trust no one who offers to help peter
in these movies so back to the question
is doctor strange mephisto i will say
hopefully not because not every liar in
the mcu is mephisto people strange is
known for quirky self-contradictions
rule breaking while there are definitely
some elements of one more day in no way
home i could see this simply as a doctor
seeing a patient in need of wizard
surgery his admonishment of peter
strange's ego projecting his mistakes on
others i just think strange is a more
interesting character if he's not
mephisto but if doctor strange in this
movie looks in a mirror and sees
mephisto staring back at him while i
will be obligated by blood curse to
stand and applaud i think most audiences
would be a bit thrown by a mirror in a
spider-man movie haunted by anyone other
than a loose norman osborne ghost in the
same way that if this whole movie were
to be revealed as part of an ongoing
illusion by mysterio plausible i guess
but it's gonna take a lot for that to
not feel a bit disappointing right
however i do believe it's not only
possible but likely that strange's
actions could be motivated by
supernatural forces like mephisto
full-blown demonic possession maybe
maybe not but strange has always been
more aware of the dark entities lurking
beyond this reality than he has led on
as mordo warned the bill comes due and
for strange i think the cost of his
mastery of the mystic arts is a mind
vulnerable to parasitic forces from
beyond when doctor strange looked ahead
at the 14605 future outcomes he emerged
from that trance shaken with fear and
fear leads people to do irrational
things and i don't think it's crazy at
all to believe that one of the things he
saw was a demon that he now as i do sees
in every shadow manifesting as every
dark thought leading strange to use a
kid's wish to bend reality to
preemptively imprison every multiversal
evil in his weird little ghostbusters
trap and the way that wand division's
post-credit scene left us with the
scarlet witch opening cosmic floodgates
from marvel's book of the damned i could
see a post-credits scene to spider-man
no way home setting up doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness with the
implication that strange's actions with
peter parker were done in the service of
or the prevention against that chilling
whisper so if mephisto is not in
spider-man no way home definitely keep
an eye out for him in multiverse of
madness and in my case every time i
close my eyes to blink oh god oh god oh
god support new rockstars by checking
out our merch options including our new
marvel what if limited edition shirt and
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching and uh again for everyone
who comments reacting to thumbnail
without watching the video honestly
every time i try to do something fun or
exciting you make it not that way i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
[Music]
you